our mission as a company is to make
private scholarships a viable
alternative to student loans
[Music]
david tavachnikov good to see you how
are you
i'm awesome how are you fantastic thank
you for being on the show
you're actually calling from serbia
right
yes thank you for having me and why
serbia
why serbia why soda actually
to be fair serbia is basically uh
has been my base after i left tel aviv
in 2016
and i've been a digital nomad for quite
a while a digital nomad what does that
mean digital nomad
a digital knowledge is somebody who is
basically location independent somebody
who
doesn't tie his work or his activities
to a specific location
um while doing his most cases doing his
job
digitally so it can be
um the web developers marketing teachers
so anything that basically just requires
a lot of fun
anything that doesn't look valuable use
your hands to assemble something
okay i like that yeah and
you're the ceo of scholarshipowl and and
you've been doing some pretty incredible
work to help
a lot a lot of people around the world
and
find scholarships and get proper
education so tell me a little bit about
that
and and what is this world of of the
education
right so um i'll start with the
basically the problem and the problem is
that in the u.s
specifically the education is extremely
expensive
and substantially more so than in
any other country and in fact in the
past
eight years the cost of tuition has been
going eight times faster than the wages
wow okay yes well how much are we
talking about tangibly here
an average family pays per student 26
000 dollars um
per year that's an average per year
right
and um i know cases of 70 and
90 000 dollars as well right numbers are
huge
yeah put that into perspective masters
degree in the uk
is kept by 9 000 pounds
okay and that's some of the most
expensive education in europe
interesting okay
so why is that so so why is that though
an issue
so yeah i mean you can say you want to
go to a better university you're going
to have to pay more
and are there not options that are
that are financially viable for
everybody is that the issue
so there are all kinds of government
programs and there's a
subject of student loans as well which
has been talked a lot
right in student loans is basically an
attempt of the government
and private companies to help students
pay those high tuition costs
i believe actually that the student debt
is the
second largest debt in the us if not the
most it is
yeah it is no it's the second one it's
1.7 trillion dollars
trillion dollars it's a big market to go
after david
it's more than many countries in the
world right and
uh it's been going by around 100 billion
dollars
a year for the world years crazy it's
crazy numbers it's crazy numbers
but the thing is that the the student
loan industry in a way it's
um it's the one that drives the tuition
it costs up
because the more loans are available the
more money the universities are taking
because they know that the students can
afford more money
interesting um okay wait so what you're
what you're describing here is this
vicious cycle where
there's more loan programs whether it's
by banks or by government the
universities see that and say okay well
actually now
every every kid on the block can just go
get a loan from the bank
pay it over 30 40 years so why don't we
just raise the tuition because
there they can just get a bigger loan
and now we're gonna
but and yeah but it's just vicious
obviously it's
it's yeah but you set a time every
kid on the block so basically you're
telling a 17 year old kid
you know take you know a hundred
thousand dollars in love crazy that you
will need to
pay with huge interest we're talking
like eight to fourteen percent
interest it's huge interests like
you know you have no no uh um
no credit history no other measurement
of how will that's right
that's right so how do you calculate the
interest and
that's how you end up with a very very
high interest wow
and you asked that from a 17 year old
kid like to make the decisions
of course he's going to be talking to
response and so but at the end of the
day but it's not a fair decision
because that kid needs an education and
if this is the only way to get an
education then it doesn't matter what
the interest rate is even if it's 20
you have to do it otherwise you're
otherwise you don't have a chance here
and let's be honest like most families
do not have twenty six thousand dollars
lying around to
per yield most families don't have four
hundred dollars to pay in an emergency
fund if the car breaks down i
i heard that in one of my economics
classes i was shocked beyond belief
exactly four hundred dollars most
families don't have is emergency money
i think you know i i just want to decide
like you know
that we grew up in a considerably more
privileged world than
than you know four billion people here
where we
can go out to restaurants we can eat we
can go to university we can study and
we're engineers and i think it's
sometimes also for me
it's hard to it's easy to forget that a
lot of others don't have these
opportunities and that's why i'm also so
excited about what you're doing with
scholarship out to level the playing
field and allow everybody there
exactly now um
student loans is one like you said it's
a vicious uh
cycle mission cycle but
um part of the money obviously comes you
know from savings that the plans are
saved but beginning the savings program
from
when right the kid is born part of that
comes from different types of
scholarships
and scholarships those a few different
types some of them are institutionals
scholarships given by the college by the
state
by the government and so on and some of
them are pilots
given either by private companies or
philanthropy funds
but different organizations which are
not related to the
education system itself right
basically any company can give out or
any brand can give out a scholarship
and they do it in many cases either
because it's considered
a donation so they get tax breaks on
that okay
other because they want to get the
message across in different ways
you know you have a scholarship for to
not to
drink and dive for example so they want
students to
get the message they offer a scholarship
what does that mean wait what does that
mean
a scholarship with the conception of
don't drink and drive basically like
in order to apply to many of those
scholarships you need to
to do something to actually apply in
many cases it can be
either an essay that's what the students
have to do
the students apply the students write
the essay or fill out the application
exactly yes but the
organization that offers the scholarship
decides what the requirements are going
to be
okay so if your organization that tries
to fight accidents
caused by then the drivers you can make
the scholarship
um like the requirement for the
scholarship to write an essay
on why drinking and diving is bad okay
which means the students
will need to research that to learn
about it i don't ask about it
and they get the message that makes
sense okay and like
just putting a tv ad or something saying
you know don't drink and dive
making a scholarship for that causes the
students to get
to you told to kill your message right
actually
you know internalize the message sure uh
so that's kind of one side of that
equation the other side is that
this scholarship and then goes to a
student in most cases those
outside scholarships are between one and
five thousand dollars um
and um no you don't need to repay them
you don't need to anything like but
right it's a scholarship it's a great
scholarship yeah exactly
but the amount of students that are one
of those scholarships are very limited
of course so where so where do you come
in so where do you come into this
equation because there's a lot of
scholarships
there's a lot of students and there's a
lot of big mishmash balagona unmatching
them
right exactly and that's exactly what
did i catch did i catch the problem
right
you cut you cut the problem precisely
okay the thing is that
finding all the scholarships with all
the requirements and all the
eligibility tools they have just going
to them it's a full-time job
right no student can do that right
um of course and on top of that
if you go to the easy scholarships like
the no essay ones or the ones with
valencia
those tens of thousands of students that
apply to them
so a huge amount of competition and they
may be award five of them
right that's that's kind of the problem
what we have done is we built
like we mapped all those kinds of
scholarships
with all the requirements of digitality
and so on and when the student comes to
us
we build the profile of the student and
we uh
match the students with all the
scholarships
that the students is eligible to they
still need to do some of the work they
still need to write an essay they still
need to do
right of course maybe we call the video
and so on
but given the data we have we will show
him on the commander student discussion
that he has the highest chance of
winning so you ask this student hey
give us a little bit of an who are you
what are your interests what are your
passions
tell us everything you can tell us and
then we will we know
of the 10 000 possible scholarships and
we know
what they're looking for so we can give
you the top 10 so that you don't have to
go to the other 990
right or the 90 000 okay but we go the
extra mile here because other than
knowing the
the ten thousand or what tens of
thousands of scholarships
right we also have um you know millions
of students on the platform so we know
how many other students are eligible for
each scholarship
okay so the the narrower goals the
higher the chances that you will win
right which means that if you invest the
same 20 minutes into writing an essay on
a scholarship
that has 10 000 applicants versus
scholarship that have
100 so so david it's like ways right you
know that there is a lot of traffic in
one lane you go to the other and this
works well because you worked four ways
so i so now i see where you got the
inspiration
definitely it's it's it's wasteful
scholarship i love it yes
i'm trying to show you this actually
that's our slogan right it's the fastest
sell to scholarships
okay you see i can come work for you
all right welcome david future minds
talk to me about that that's your newest
venture like
just before we go to future minds um
scholarship
is our student site yeah and last year
we launched
scholarship app which is our
brand and the organization side which is
basically a clm and cms
that helps organizations to offer
scholarships
easily basically to manage the
scholarship
itself manage the applicants manage the
right
the winners and so on right and we
offered scholarship apps
completely for free okay um
with the intention to make the private
scholarship space aston spun
and dustworthy as possible
so basically like any any organization
or company can
come over and within 15 minutes publish
a scholarship and offer it
basically increasing the amount of
supply of scholarships
to the demand from the students
obviously we connect the two sites
okay amazing our mission as a company
is to make private scholarships a viable
alternative to student loans
yeah so a student goes to our platform
and
if for now doesn't replace the student
loans completely at least
takes a substantial bike out of student
loans and owns a lot less but david what
is the
how is the market balanced so how many
students so every year how many how much
money do students
need in scholarships and how much money
is available through
the 10 000 possible scholarships is it
about the same amount or
because i in my mind you i would imagine
there is a huge disparity
so some of the students we work with
have won
tens of thousands of dollars just in
private scholarships
and some of the advisors we worked with
got hundreds of thousands of dollars in
paris scholarships
the majority of students get nothing eve
at all
yeah and that disability is exactly
because of that because it's so hard
to know what to apply to if you have a
good system and you know what you're
doing
you will win scholarships okay
but and obviously every amount helps it
doesn't even have to be even
i don't need the full ride but even just
getting me there
substantially reduces the stress the
anxiety
but also you know the confidence that i
need to go and get my academic education
we like to think of that that way
thousand dollars in scholarships was
what fifteen hundred dollars in uh
student loans
makes sense because that and that's i
guess
mainly looking at the interest right
it's not just the interest
it's well first you you anyway need to
invest the work right if you
like the scholarship you need to invest
it becomes front loaded you need to
invest the work
at the beginning right if you go the
student loan
out you need to pay it later with
interest
with right when you're in a different
place in your life yeah
basically you know you start paying your
student loans well it depends on many
conditions but basically healthy after
you
graduate sure if you drop out which
and the statistics of dropping out are
pretty awful right
okay and in fact 41 percent of the
students that drop out
are dropping out because of financial
reasons wow that's insane nobody
but i do want to also in my mind i can
see the viability of the
of the psychological aspect of it you're
getting a scholarship as as
for any amount whether it's a thousand
dollars or ten thousand dollars that
vote of confidence that somebody's
giving you and saying i believe in you
go and get your education
i think that has some impact but we but
i can't believe we only have about five
minutes left and we have to do
future minds and i want to talk about
the fact that you're completely remote
which in the age of covet and the new
2020 it's so relevant
but first future minds tell me what this
is about
so you mentioned covet um
this week we launched future mines fund
which is uh
based on the infrastructure and the
products we already have
it's all it's a non-profit organization
which is
made to help students that were impacted
by profit 19 finish their education
we believe that if the students that
will drop out because of kovit won't
finish their education
we won't have professionals tomorrow to
build the world we won't have the future
researchers to to you know cure the next
pandemic
right and we have to save this
generation because
the students of 2020 were hurt the most
in 20 years
like it's the impact that this pandemic
had on the students
is bigger than on many other areas of
life
right and future minds fund is built in
a way that
we uh two our platforms uh students can
apply to those
scholarships basically launched we begin
by launching three scholarships
ourselves
which were targeted at students that
lost their income
while studying so if you had a side job
and things like that
and you lost it and you cannot finish
your studies because of them
right um as students that had
to launch the whole living situation
because they needed to now study from
home
right you know you used to study a
little biblio and now you need a desk
you need a chair you need a desk you
need a yeah you need a chat you need a
laptop you need maybe some books
there's a lot of things you need which
you didn't count for sure like you said
400 dollars can be a lot of money
sure now suddenly you need to set up the
whole employment
so we launched three scholarships by
ourselves
basically the scholarships that are
targeted at helping
students that lost their side income
during the studies um because many
uh the students are dependent on side
income and you had six thousand
applicants right
and we had over six thousand dollars wow
one weekend alone
one weekend so we saw and these are of
students that were impacted by covet and
they need assistance to complete their
studies this is not just
any random person only comment crazy
the scholarship you launched only
covered 1911. so
so where is this headed can other
organizations come and also
provide scholarships after like after we
saw the demand
which was way bigger than we anticipated
we reached out to a few other
organizations the higher education space
to help us out in that way we've been
able to award 19 scholarships
wow ourselves but when we saw the
potential of that
we decided to open it to the general
public yeah um
and we'll launch the nonprofit
organization and
fund dedicated to that on which anybody
basically can um
go to our website see the story of each
student
separately like how it was impacted what
happened and then it's like a gofundme
where they can sponsor a student
i love it and then you're creating the
personal attachment it's a public
funding campaign for students i love it
david
very inspiring is this do you see this
specific for covet and that's it do you
see this on the long term as a way for
students to share their story and get
and get assistance for education where
do you see this going
i mean our immediate goal was to help
the students were impacted now
but i don't see why that wouldn't become
a more permanent thing
right you know helping different causes
and different
helping students impacted by different
uh
situations or conditions that are
happening i love at the u.s
yeah david very quickly how long have
the
have you been with scholarship owl or
has the company been
living as a whole um i've been with the
scholastic pilot since 2015.
and and how many how many people are in
it
we're now 35 people 35 people and
everybody's remote right
all remote as i like to say was spread
from vegas to bali
i love it okay so david we're gonna have
to do another episode which will be
featured
a few months from now where we only talk
about this remote thing because i think
that is just as relevant
to it to this whole new 2020 and i need
to learn how to start working
a full-time remote because i think we
all have to learn that now
i i think that hobbit has basically
accelerated the remote
workspace
david right before we leave i need three
words that you would best describe
yourself
and i'm gonna ask you the same question
in a few months when we do the next
episode so make sure to be consistent
according to remember right
describe my myself
ginger be fair
committed and um
and killers i love it jinji committed
and curious it's
beautiful david thank you very much
and best of luck with scholarship i
really hope you get to help these
thousands of of the of students now
during covet and
and thank you for the work that you're
doing for the millions of others and
that need assistance
on a yearly basis going into college and
i think you're doing a great great
service to to all of them so thank you
thank you very much for having me take
care bye-bye
hey